we have had a trend of the woke
feminists infiltrating the media this
has happened for like a hundred years
however we have seen
feminism really going crazy in Disney
right now so recently Disney cast
a Snow White
who hates Snow White let's show the clip
you said you were bringing a Modern Edge
to it on stage what do you mean by that
I just mean that it's no longer 1937 and
we absolutely wrote a snow white that is
not going to be saved by the prince he's
not going to be safe with a prince and
she's not going to be dreaming about
true love she's dreaming about becoming
the leader she knows she can be and the
leader that her late father told her
that she could be if she was Fearless
Fair Brave and true and so it's just a
really incredible story for I think
young people everywhere to see
themselves in nobody is running for
president
I'm launching my campaign do you see
this delusion
it's like sweetheart the only reason
anybody cares what you have to say is
because you're pretty
you know what I mean like we live in
this delusion where we care about a 21
year old's political opinions
she's not smart not intelligent she's
just pretty so they'll kind of let her
let her talk like they literally let us
live in delusion so let me get this
straight
you think a good message for women is
that you don't need a prince to save you
when men run all of society when you do
need men to protect you when you do need
men to build the buildings that you
shoot in when you do need men to build
the house that you live in in the police
force you and you think it's a good
message that women don't want to get
love from men like there's a reason
women have been so brainwashed into
thinking we deserve these like tens of
men like there there really is a reason
and it's because like women innately
like we know that we want love you know
that you want that like I don't know
soulmate that they sell us on this
nonsense but my point is now they're
trying to make us into men men are
supposed to chase their purpose women
are supposed to chase men and now we
have this Society where Snow White this
this chick is trying to change the whole
story into something it's not and
brainwash the next generation of women
it's really a sad cycle and it's an
absolute sad cycle and women don't
really hit reality until their looks
start to fade because we can really just
say whatever nonsense and get away with
it until it starts to go unfortunately